[Music]
yo what's up Game of Thrones toad what
yo you all caught up you know totally
bears watch that whole thing last night
so it's cold blooded up in Westeros it
starts you ain't see now or coming into
Hey I mean my man was just dead right
you got down there and I worry they
gonna kill my point man starts lip and
then plop like cold-blooded up in there
and then I was like but that's okay
because I still got my big Dave Navarro
thing saving the farmers yeah I do
picked up some molten gold I mean he's
like you can't kill cobbles or the paper
and in fact is scratching so he got
straight killed which is y'all but you
know what my favorite character is it
Khaleesi sleaze no I'll be liking some
khaleesies door but what about
khaleesies straight-up whipped and
Dragons as police is all like this
straight roasting goats oh my god that's
when they start killing characters left
and right dog no guilt no kills
that was a four-for-one dog one up to go
straight for for one don't want to put
about when they got wildlings girl
talking about
No
Celt slowly by omission yo who would buy
my man Taiwan Lannisters Taiwan
Lannisters to stop talking about I'm
taking his kills by his own son
what dingo dinkles wrinkles no the dingo
dinkles is my jam
nobody count the deck they think us is
my jam my jelly my peanut butter and my
peanuts students goals
[Music]
you